but of course coronavirus remains the
big story of the day and earlier on we
heard where she sunix saying that the
government will provide extra support
for the NHS and business to deal with
the impact of the outbreak if needed
well to discuss that further we're
joined now by the chair of the Royal
College of GPs professor Martin Marshall
thank you very much for being with us
good morning today and we heard earlier
from where she sue not talking about
more money for the NHS if necessary in
the budget does the Health Service need
more resources to tackle coronavirus yes
you know it almost certainly does this
is a this is a significant crisis for
the health service health services
already under pressure as we know if
we're going to contrive to continue
doing what we are doing in the health
service and deal with coronavirus it
requires a significant amount of
resource more likely I suspect we will
cut down on some of the routine work
that's done by a Health Service in order
to allow the energy has to focus on
dealing with the coronavirus I mean
routine what we're talking about and
non-emergency operation has been
cancelled and that kind of thing I think
that's likely we don't know yet we're
not certain but I think it's likely so
the kind of routine operations hip
replacements knee replacements hernias
and duskily - those kind of things where
you're not worried about cancer
relatively routine clearly a great
inconvenience for patients but but not
life or death yeah and we're talking
about the resources of NHS you were
saying how their lectures is already
quite stretched and you've got new
record waiting times at A&E we've we've
seen lots of people on long waiting list
for operations as well is the Health
Service prepared to deal with this kind
of emergency situation I think it is I
think it is I mean it is difficult
because we don't know what the scale of
the emergency will be at the moment some
of the figures that we're saying are the
worst possible scenario and I think
we're right to plan for those the NHS is
very good at dealing with crises like
this and it's proved that time and time
again in in the past it doesn't mean
that there's no implications as we say
for routine procedures for example but
the NHS is well resourced it has really
good planning mechanisms and we know how
to deal with these kind of crises you
were talking about some of the worst
case scenario numbers being floated
around the Sunday Times reporting today
ministers are working from what they
described as a central estimate
100,000 deaths from coronavirus I mean
does that sound realistic it's very
difficult to tell we know that around
about 17,000 patients a year die of flu
and so we know that these kind of
viruses can be can be very serious
100,000 is it's probably more like a
worst case scenario I suspect it depends
on whether we manage to continue to
contain the virus in the way that we are
doing at the moment it looks like the
numbers are going up and they'll
probably continue doing so it doesn't
look like we need to shift from the
contain phase to a more of a delay phase
which has a number of advantages we just
don't know how it's going to play out
it's difficult isn't it it would be lots
of speculation like no social distancing
canceling big meetings big concerts or
playing football behind closed doors is
that kind of preparation effective yes
it is yes it is we know this is an
infectious disease which is transmitted
mostly through droplet infections so
coughing sneezing and when those the
products of costs or sneeze get on the
hands or on the hard objects then
transmits that way so we know that
maintaining social distance keeping
people apart from large events for
example or even from work places more
people working from home for example is
highly effective and in many ways this
is this is basic hygiene this is about
hand washing it's about keeping people
apart and stopping the spreading I'm
interested to know a little bit about
and the impact on GPS as well that's
been talked about asking retires GPS to
come back and help out effectively and
in if it does become more serious I mean
do you think that is a good idea and at
the same time I guess that many things
GPS could be in the at-risk age category
themselves I think it is a good idea as
long as long as we do it carefully
people are estimating that maybe 20% of
the workforce might be out of action at
any one time when the crisis reads it
reaches its peak the people are talking
about maybe sometime in April late April
for that if that happens then we do need
to expand the workforce in in whatever
way we can the suggestions at the moment
from the chief medical officer are that
people who within a couple of years of
retirement so they still might have
their registration could be quickly get
back get back onto the medical register
and would be able to practice most
likely those doctors because as you say
they would be likely to be in the
high-risk group would not do face to
face patient
but there's lots of other things that
they can do managing 1 1 1 providing
online care for example or telephone
based care for patients do you think GPS
will will listen to the call [ __ ] GPS
or do you think they'll be reluctant to
you know come back into work
I've been confident that they'd respond
positively I think that's that's where
doctors are trained for doctors tend to
respond very positively when in states
of emergency
we've also seen a GP surgeries closing
even if temporarily if it's found that
someone who's been into contact with the
surgery has tested positive for
coronavirus is that best practice or is
there a worry that you know if GP
surgery starts closing then it could
have a big impact for health provision
well it's a difficult balance isn't it
and in each of these cases there's no
absolute answer so on one side if we
know that somebody has it maybe infected
a building or infected staff within a
building it makes sense to isolate that
building or the other side if you then
if that then results in no one in a
local community getting care then that's
a problem so there's always a delicate
balance between overreacting and
under-reacting
to these to these problems at the moment
we're still at the phase where if it
looks like somebody has infected in an
enclosed area then you should isolate
that area you should shut it down
whether that will still be the case in a
few weeks time I think it's difficult to
tell yeah as you say always responding
to the most up-to-date advice in a
situation and on that how do you think
the government has in handling over
situations so far I think well I think I
think it's clearly a difficult situation
we know that this is an emergency we
know it's going to get worse than it is
now the job of government is to plan for
the worst scenario but also to reassure
the community people as best they can at
the same time I think they're doing
pretty well it's very easy to pick out
areas where things haven't gone exactly
right where maybe advice has been
contradictory if anything particularly
detail yeah particularly I mean I
there's no specific cases you know
sometimes where one part of government
is saying one thing and the other part
of government to say another thing I
think you know I think that's probably
inevitable at a time when we're learning
rapidly in the situation is moving
rapidly overall I think that government
is probably doing a pretty good job in
this country and that's one of the
reasons why we've got just over 200
cases in comparison with other countries
that have got far more thank you very
much for coming up on the program giving
your
view on where we are with coronavirus
much appreciated